le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais la route de la
montagne la route départementale 40 et
une offre une vue imprenable sur la
ville de saint denis le conseil général
a décidé en 2013 sur demande de
passionnés de randonnées et l'histoire
de réhabiliter un sentier oublié qui
suit au plus près le tracé de la
première voie de communication entre le
nord et l'ouest de l'île pour le plaisir
des dionysiens des touristes et plus
largement de tous les réunionnais car
s'il est une pratique qui est
particulièrement apprécié des
réunionnais c'est bien la randonnée
notre île offre des paysages
époustouflants qu'on ne peut pas se
lasser de découvrir ou de redécouvrir
quel est ce sentier son histoire sa
situation on en parle tout de suite dans
lien social
ce sont d'abord des passionnés qui ont
retrouvé ce sentier partant de la
redoute et rejoignant le chemin de la
vigie en reliant les différents sites
présentant une valeur historique
avant 1730 c'était par la mer que ce
effectuer des échanges entre saint paul
et saint denis c'est en 1770 qu'un
chemin est ouvert on l'appellera
successivement chemin saint paul chemin
boissons ou chemin crémont mais il est
actuellement plus connu sous le nom de
chemin des anglais en référence aux
troupes britanniques qui l'empruntaient
pour vaincre les forces françaises à la
redoute en 1810 il y à peu près quatre
ans paul henri lebon montagnards à 6 ème
journée du patrimoine à saint bernard
dans les hauts de la montagne et
rencontre des personnes qui font partie
de la commission sentiers et patrimoine
il se souvient d'un sentier qui le
prenaient pour rejoindre la ville et
qu'empruntait sa maman et sa grand mère
mais également tous les anciens pour
retrouver ce sentier au début il a fallu
déjà se mettre en bas
pour quelque chose et après rente est
rentré dans la broussaille dans les
épines un chai crapahuter c'est de
retrouver le sentier on n'a pas un type
à vesa pas été trop difficile il ya un
peu d'âme qui ont poussé dedans mais en
fait elle est partie avec lui rien la
nature avait repris complètement ces
droits là commence pour un peu seulement
et ensuite on leur propose de bonnes
volontés de la montagne ce qu'ils
voulaient des gens la commission la
russian venir donner un coup de main
pour nettoyer dont on l'a retrouvé le
sentier on a retrouvé le tracé des
pièces jointes
le valais fait de ne pas peu dire que
bon ben il sentit n'est pas sécurisé il
traverse la route donc c'est dangereux
et à portland où un effet pris les
choses en main et ils ont entièrement
restauré le 1er et le conseil général
doit entièrement restauré le seul outil
c'est à dire avant c'était un sentier
abrupt direct et là ils ont fait plus
confortable plus accessible à plus grand
nombre mais en faisant quand même
attention à ne pas oublier
la partie patrimoniale de ce sentier ce
dialecte roi conscient pavés qui restent
en suisse entre la grande chaloupe qui
est un pagne au qui dit que ce sentier
il allait de la possession jusqu'à saint
denis mais en fait la partie saint denis
on a payé c'est plus qu il faut arriver
à saint-benoît s'arrêter là un des
intérêts de ce sentier c'est
le rando montagne à tous les pratiquait
autrefois donner quelque chose à nos
enfants le donner ce sentier là le donné
la nature de la vraie vie parce que
actuellement ce qu'on la donne c'est
tout c'est joli trou de
joli 2 tout ça
c'est dommage ce genre de choses a
enrichi ce certain personne n'est pas
nous ce pas forcément les autres mais
invite les gens à venir emprunter ce
sentier les gens qui habitent saint
denis bertsulari outre découvrir un
autre sentiment qu'on regarde la
montagne vent de la montagne à druelle
en fait se sentir le n9 l'afrique
confortable
c'est tout aussi important c'est
progressif donc il est anticipé donc pas
mal de gens et à venez découvrir aussi
un patrimoine historique
la bâtiment tendu santé des anglais et
puis bien vite aussi un autre public le
public des gens qui vont travailler à
saint-denis
d'aller travailler à pied par exemple si
les comptes sont régalés des
sans-papiers remonter à pied y en a pour
une heure donc il trouve que ça allait
faisable les marcheurs apprécié ce
nouveau sentier ils nous donnent leurs
avis et leurs impressions un sentier
très agréable sentier double ou les
débutants qui remise à niveau est haut
comme ça ben on a fait un joli travail
bien nettoyer bien propre ben a
l'habitude qu'ont commis entre elles
mais là mais il recommence voilà ce que
ça me faisait sentir fin de compte sinon
ça c'est le côté le colorado mais voilà
comme comme les rôles et pour remise à
niveau
la santé est assez facile et accessible
à tout le monde donc voilà c'est pour ça
que je me fais de temps en temps bah
disons que c'est assez pratique mais
après au niveau sonore
donc c'est comme sait pas trop quand
même les voitures etc
le conseil général propriétaire de 95%
des forêts publiques en partenariat avec
le wef a la responsabilité de préserver
ce patrimoine naturel et permet ainsi à
plus de 3 millions de visiteurs de le
découvrir en toute sécurité
ce sentier périurbain familiale
s'ajoutent aux 850 km de sentiers qui
chaque année sont aménagés et où
entretenu avec la forte volonté d'offrir
aux randonneurs des sentiers de qualité
et sécurisés un investissement pour la
collectivité de plus de 3,5 millions
d'euros qui permet la création de 600
emplois
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais